. A Twitter spokesperson has confirmed to
Fox, I'm sorry to Forbes, that after Inauguration
Day, Donald Trump can be banned from Twitter
right now.
Twitter has a rule called the world leaders
policy, which means that the social media
company typically will leave up any tweets
from world leaders, even if they violate Twitter
policy at a more granular level.
And their explanation is when it's a head
of state, people want to see what heads of
state are saying.
And so even if the comments violate Twitter
policy, we leave them up.
And that's the policy that has allowed Donald
Trump to spread conspiracy theories about
coronavirus and the election and tweet threats
and get people bullying others without being
punished.
And the protection will stop when Trump is
no longer president on January 20th.
Now, the reality is he's never really been
a leader, but he has technically been the
president of the United States.
The normal process when you don't have world
leader protection, is that the first time
you tweet something that violates policy,
your account is blocked until you delete that
tweet.
The second time you break policy, your account
is frozen for some period of time.
That happened to Don Jr.
I think it was 12 hours over.
False claims about coronavirus might have
been about hydroxy chloroquine and eventually
you would be banned altogether.
If Donald Trump does get banned by Twitter,
it will trigger him incredibly.
And it would be a pleasure to watch.
But I would rather Twitter get rid of the
rule that you can be exempt from the guidelines.
Everybody should have to play by the same
rules.
And if that were the case, Donald Trump would
already have been banned for targeting people,
for bullying people, for consistently spreading
disinformation about elections and public
health matters.
Shouldn't you be held to a higher standard
as president?
Because in practice, what Twitter is saying
is we hold world leaders to a lower standard.
And that seems counterintuitive to me.
Now, there's an interesting kind of side story
here, which is that Donald Trump has been
losing Twitter followers since he lost the
election.
If you look at social blade, which tracks
data for social accounts of all kinds, it
shows that over the last 30 days, Trump has
lost about three hundred thousand followers.
That's about 10000 followers per day.
And this is interesting because we've been
covering the many ways in which the world
has been moving on from Donald Trump and Donald
Trump throughout his presidency gained followers
and now he is losing followers.
And again, the world is moving on now.
Big picture, I actually like world leaders
being on Twitter.
I follow Justin Trudeau.
I follow Argentinean elected officials and
I follow the French president.
And I like hearing from elected officials
in this direct way.
What Trump does really wrong is he tweets
things that affect policy or he tweets new
policy without even communicating with anybody
that he's planning to do that.
The military trans is one where Jim Mattis,
the secretary of defense, was traveling and
unaware Trump was doing this and Trump tweeted
it.
And it creates chaos.
And, of course, the brazen way in which Trump
uses the bully pulpit to target bullying at
individuals and to spread disinformation.
It's disgusting.
But Trump aside, I like world leaders being
on Twitter.
Let me know what you think.
We'll have more coverage of this on our Instagram
page, which you can find at The David Pakman
Show, The David Pakman Show at David Pakman
dot com.